today is take your child to work day
emphasis on your get that part wrong it
could be take yourself to jail day now
half of me hates this day I don't like
sharing the elevator with people who are
one-tenth my age but 100 percent my
Heights Plus this means dana has to
watch her language in the halls and we
all know how filthy she is also it's
hard to fire someone who has their kid
with them it's how do you do that maybe
tell the parent to wait outside then
tell the kid hey your dad's fired so
take your child to work day has now
become the day you can't swear or fire
any one day and that's wrong for people
like Dana who enjoy swearing and making
people cry also I don't have kids so
today is really no different than
yesterday except with more screaming
which scares the kids when I do it but
the other half of the embraces this day
after all it's good that your kids see
what people do for a living they need to
learn that money isn't something that
mysteriously regenerates in a wallet mom
and dad have to work to pay for your
clothes your toys you're worthless
politically-correct
overpriced education and really work is
often the thing you know least about
your parents I remember my dad taking me
to work and it was thrilling I drove the
getaway car but that's where I learned
about the magical money in the wallet
and it's great to see another place
where your parents were somebody else
and not in a bathrobe they had a role
outside your world it's where you learn
your parents aren't just parents but
human beings who are hated by other
human beings so enjoy this day but if
your kid touches anything on my desk
you're dead so you know by the way it's
Earth they've made Earth Day Earth week
and today's take your child to work so
I've combined it I take my plant to work
day this is a very that all day yeah
this is Tyler you know he's my one and
only he looks dry let me water that that
was his water and you're in his world
have you seen a lot of children roaming
the halls see miles who is the four
month old son of our produce one of our
producers Brett Zoeller he's very cute
is very very cute and I saw a couple of
other kids house but how can I wait a
minute wait did he took a four month old
to take your child to work day
I'm here to visit us you know people
bring their babies in like this but the
babies are gonna learn anything they're
starting early they're starting back up
yes by the way Brett changed the baby on
your desk Greg bringing kids to work one
day a year yes is a good thing see I
disagree I think one that it should not
be an orchestrated thing bring your kid
whenever you want it's more exciting you
think that would be better than one day
I was a child before this this holiday
this fake thing next was gonna be cards
my dad showed me my dad was an
accountant that was thrilling to me did
you have like a little app yeah a little
a little calculator account 1970 you
know I remember about this is once I
took my daughter and and she was at my
desk at the Washington Post and she kept
that picture forever yeah it was like
wow it's a big deal to her I think that
just to see where your dad and you're
gone all the time so where is e this is
where this is where dad goes to pay for
that food I wish they made that
connection I'm not sure I saw my
daughter today and she asked me if I had
more than a thousand dollars in my bank
account and she was really impressed I
was on the trampoline when your
contracts up they're gonna play this
back in the meeting he comes in at 4:30
Emily what are your thoughts on this did
you ever you're young enough that you
probably went to take your child like
older than you are yes and my mom was a
librarian loves going to it I love going
was your dad a pathologist and my mom
was a librarian so like those are great
you know and it was like Quincy meets go
ahead okay and like for example my lunch
bag was a specimen bag which I realized
at the time was super normal and then
later I realized how actually odd that
was you know it's like
the organs my point is that I think we
should actually have a bring your dog to
work day which is so much oh they do
have that in most places and do not
encourage that I think it's this Friday
at Fox no no bring your dog to work day
when is that someone just told me about
that oh come on takes her dog around
everywhere he's being raised as a
service dog Jasper to work it would be
like great what Ellen it's to the robots
what happens when the robots what will
they bring to work will they bring a
toaster little robot I hope you didn't
get a liver sandwich there's some joke
you have to ask yourself if your kids
can't come to your place at work
well yeah certain places can accept
children the Port Authority